لا يتعلق الأمر بجود بيلينجهام
الآن دون إجابتي بالتأكيد ، لكن
الأمر كان جيدًا دائمًا لم
أفهمه أبدًا ، لذا فأنا
لماذا
نتحدث باستمرار عن أشياء
لا يمكننا نظريًا امتلاكها ، لذلك لا يمكننا
الحصول على ستة لاعبين في الصيف مقابل
100 مليون لكل شخص على سبيل المثال
سيقول الجميع أنه حسنًا ، هذا
نوع من الوضوح ، وهذا هو الشيء الذي عليك أن
تدرك ما يمكنك فعله ومن ثم عليك
العمل معه ، لذا كم من المال
لدينا متاح ومن ثم عليك
العمل معه وهذا  هذه هي
الوظيفة التي يجب عليك القيام بها ، ولا يتعلق الأمر بأننا
لسنا أطفالًا ،
أقصد أن أسأل طفلة تبلغ من العمر خمس سنوات
في عيد الميلاد عما تريده
لعيد الميلاد وأقول لك إنني أريد أن
لا أعرف سيارة فيراري  لن أقول
أوه هذه فكرة جيدة ستقول
لا ، إنها باهظة الثمن وبأي طريقة
لا يمكنك قيادتها